hi my name is nina jagadison and i'm
going to be talking about individual
fairness and advertising auctions
through inverse proportionality and this
is joint work with shuchi chawla
so there's been lots of evidence of sku
delivery in online advertising so
similarly qualified people from
different gender and racial groups can
end up seeing
differing amounts of ads in sensitive
categories
like housing and employment
so the first and most obvious source of
unfairness is that the advertiser
targeting is itself unfair so what in
particular maybe the advertiser
targeting parameters um are set to be
uninclusive or the um individual
advertisers bids look otherwise unfair
in some way
so this source of unfairness can be
directly audited by looking at each
advertiser's behavior in isolation so
the second source of unfairness which is
more subtle
is that the platform's allocation
algorithm can create unfairness even
when the bids are fair
so to see this
consider the employment category
it's been demonstrated that there can be
skewed delivery and employment ads even
when each advertiser uh
targeting is gender-neutral similarly
there can be skewed delivery in housing
ads even when each advertiser's
targeting parameters are inclusive
so the takeaway from these empirical
studies is that unfairness can arise
solely from the platform's allocation
algorithm
um so the goal of our work is to um
provide a fairness framework that
eliminates
the second source of unfairness we focus
on eliminating the unfairness that's
introduced by the platform's allocation
algorithm
so to get some intuition for why the
platform's allocation algorithm can
introduce unfairness um let's consider
the following example so suppose that
there are two users alice and bob
and
two advertisers both in the category of
employment so let's say one of the
advertisers is a big tech company and
the other advertiser is a startup
so let's say that um both the big tech
company and the startup bid very
similarly on alice and bob but the big
tech company slightly prefers alice to
bob and the startup slightly prefers bob
to alice so if the platform um runs
allocates uh each alice's ad slot to the
advertiser that bid highest on alice and
allocates bob's ad slot to the
advertiser that bid highest on bob then
we would see that alice would see the
big tech company ad and bob would see
the startup ad
so in this sense the highest bid wins
auction can exaggerate small
fluctuations in bits
so um we show that this exaggeration is
not just theoretical but can actually be
seen on um real world data so in
particular we looked at the yahoo ads
data set
um and demonstrated that the highest bid
wins auction is unfair even when each
advertiser bids fairly so our we're
going to provide a formal definition of
unfairness um in a couple of minutes
um so for now the x-axis basically
parametrizes the level of unfairness in
the bids with one being corresponding to
the bids being totally fair and higher
levels corresponding to some unfairness
in the bids and the y-axis corresponds
to the level of unfairness in the
allocation
so what we see from this figure is that
even when the bids are very very close
to perfectly fair there can still be
substantial unfairness in the allocation
so this sort of demonstrates issues um
with the highest bid wins these standard
auction formats like the highest bid
wins auction and demonstrates ways in
which standard
auctions can introduce unfairness into
uh the allocations
okay so let's look at the model that we
study in this paper so we study ad
auctions in the online setting so
there's a universe of users that arrive
sequentially um and
each of k advertisers has a valuation
for every user so every user corresponds
um or is associated with this vector of
um k values corresponding to how much
each advertiser values that user
um so the auction allocates a single
slot per user so we can think of a user
as being assigned a distribution over
the k advertisers
we assume that the allocation rule
satisfies weak monotonicity so that it
can be um implemented in an incentive
compatible fashion
um and we kind of measure the
performance of an allocation rule um
using social welfare so this is the uh
sum
or the expected value of um
over the distribution of um the auctions
allocation of how much the advertiser
values um the user uh
the user to slot that we're considering
and then we sum this over all users
um so the benchmark for social welfare
is the unfair optimal which corresponds
to um the max value um of an advertiser
who bids on a given user so this would
correspond to um what
what would happen if
uh the maximum possible social welfare
of any allocation role
so our goal in this uh work is to design
ad auctions that don't introduce
unfairness and investigate trade-offs
between fairness and social welfare in
this online ad auction setting
okay so there's been a lot of related
work um about fairness and ad actions um
fairness in other settings and also um
some work on trade-offs between fairness
and social welfare in the context of
classification
so um let's kind of define uh the
fairness constraint that we study more
formally so we consider a fairness
constraint that it's expressed as a
stability condition
so our starting point is individual
fairness which stipulates that similar
users obtain similar allocations
so we think of this as a stability
requirement if two users have similar
values from all advertisers then they
should receive similar allocations so
the motivation for this is recall that
we're focused on the unfairness
introduced by the ad auction
platform
um and we assume that we've kind of
audited away um audited advertiser bids
to ensure that they're fair so now the
point is um
if we have two uh similarly qualified
users then we um after this auditing
process the advertisers um will have
been forced to bid similarly on these
two users and now the stability
requirement is guaranteeing that the
platform um ad auction is um actually
producing similar allocations for these
usages
so notice that this stability
requirement doesn't require explicit uh
specification of the fairness metric and
infers everything it needs to know kind
of from the advertiser values so we view
this as one sort of advantage of this uh
formulating fairness as a stability
requirement
okay so to define this formally an
allocation is value stable um
if with respect to a function that maps
one to infinity to zero to one if the
following condition holds for every pair
of users so what we require
is if the two value vectors for the
users are multiplicatively close then
the allocation vectors need to be
additively close so in particular
let's say that um each advertiser
bids within a factor of lambda on the
two users then we require that um the
allocation that that each advertiser
receives on the two users is um
the difference between these two
allocations uh probabilities is at most
f of lambda so this function f is
parameterizing sort of the strength of
the value stability condition so we
think of this as it takes as input some
multiplicative difference and uh
specifies the maximum allowable additive
difference uh in the allocations
so the reason that we specify uh
closeness in values multiplicatively is
that it's scale and variant and the
reason that we specify um closeness in
allocations additively is this sort of
aligns with the spirit of individual
fairness and also captures the
probability that a user um would
actually that the two users actually end
up seeing different ads
okay so um essentially if the platform
uses an value stable allocation rule we
view this as sort of guaranteeing that
the auction itself does not introduce
any further unfairness other than what
might be present already in the
advertiser's bits
okay so let's kind of get a sense of
what types of families of value
constraints are um
are
informative and reasonable to consider
so in particular consider this family of
value stability constraints parametrized
by l
um f of where given by f of l of lambda
is one minus lambda to the negative two
l
so here we see that when l gets really
close to zero um this is a very strong
value stability uh constraint
it's essentially saying that even when
the um
when the values are pretty far
multiplicatively the constraint on the
um allocation differences is pretty
strong on the other hand
as l goes to infinity
this curve becomes much
the value stability constraint becomes
much less strong so even when um the
allocation value or the value vectors
are close um
multiplicatively the al the stipulation
on the allocation vectors uh is not very
strong
so kind of in this family here um l
parameterizes the strength of the value
stability constraint
um and in general you can uh
you should think of the
reasonable value stability constraints
as any sort of function that's
increasing
and interpolates between zero and one in
this way
okay so now that we've defined uh the
model and the framework let me give um
an overview of our algorithmic results
so we examined the trade-off between
value stability and social welfare
um and our main contribution is a family
of value stable auctions that achieve a
constant fraction of the social welfare
compared to the unfair optimal
um so in particular this sort of induces
a pretty uh low cost of fairness um and
this guarantee holds this constant
fraction of the social welfare is
obtained regardless of the number of
advertisers in the system
um
in particular we also show that our
auctions actually achieve near optimal
trade-offs between value stability and
social welfare under fairly mild
assumptions
we also extend our results to stronger
notions of fairness um on subsets of
users and also when there are multiple
categories of ads when the fairness uh
definitions uh should look a little
different
and then we also in addition to these
theoretical results provide experiments
on the yahoo data set um and
uh
show that illustrate the performance of
um our family of ad auctions
okay so for the remainder of the talk
i'm going to be focusing on this uh the
these value stable auctions that we
design and the properties that they have
okay so let's just kind of recall what
the value stability condition says so
essentially recall that it if it
requires that if two value vectors are
multiplicatively close then the
allocation vectors need to be additively
close in particular their difference
needs to be bounded by f of lambda and
this is kind of an l infinity condition
on the allocation vectors we require
this um for every advertiser
um and we measure the performance of our
allocation algorithms uh by measuring
the social welfare in comparison to the
unfair optimal so this is uh basically
we sum over all users look at the social
welfare uh obtained on each user and
then divide by this um benchmark which
is kind of the sum over users of the
maximum value that any advertiser places
on that user
so the goal here is to design value
stable allocation algorithms that
achieve a near optimal approximation
ratio
okay so essentially what value stability
is requiring is some kind of a
smoothness condition so uh recall that
the highest bid wins auction kind of
exaggerated these small differences in
the bids um value stability is
essentially requiring that um
these uh sharp forms of exaggeration um
and disallowing these sharp forms of
exaggeration
okay so a first attempt at defining um
value stability or value stable at
auctions would be proportional
allocation so the idea here is just set
the allocation proportional to the
values so um
the allocation here um for a given
advertiser is how much that advertiser
values uh the user divided by um the sum
of how much all of the uh
each of the advertisers values that user
so it's uh not difficult to show that
value stability does hold for um
proportional allocation
with respect to this function f of
lambda equals one minus lambda to the
negative one which was in that family of
value stability constraints that i
mentioned before
however the main problem with
proportional allocation is the
approximation ratio
so the problem here is that the
approximation ratio actually goes to
zero as the number of advertisers goes
to infinity
so to see that um consider a value
vector with one high bid and then a
bunch or one high value and then a bunch
of small values
so we see here that essentially as k
goes to infinity the allocation that the
um proportional allocation places on the
value one is going to zero so as a
result this approximation ratio is going
to zero
so this problem actually is uh persists
for any allocation rule that allocates
proportionally to a function of the
value so this is even if we sort of
consider a more general class of
allocation algorithms where we take a
function of values and then allocate
proportionally to the function of the
values we'd still have this problem as k
goes to infinity
so um
this sort of demonstrates that to get uh
to to get a good approximation ratio
when the number of advertisers is large
we need to move outside of the family of
proportional allocation algorithms
so our main contribution from an
algorithmic perspective is this family
of inverse proportional allocation um
algorithms that um sort of addresses
this problem
so the core idea here is to rather than
uh allocating proportionally to the
values deduct proportionally to the
inverse of the values
so start by allocating
the ad slot to every user and then
deduct proportionally
to the inverse of the values and keep
kind of deducting until the sum of the
allocations across all advertisers is
one
so here at some point um if uh
advertiser bit places a particularly low
value on the user this they might sort
of hit zero so that we keep kind of
deducting uh remove advertisers as soon
as their allocation hits zero and then
continue deducting
um and so we can sort of write this as
setting t so that the sum
of uh max zero and one minus t over the
value is uh equal to one
so although it's not clear from the way
i describe the algorithm here we show in
the paper that t can actually be
computed efficiently
and so we can have a more um an
efficient implementation of this
algorithm
so let me give an overview of the
performance of inverse proportional
allocation
so the first property is that it
achieves an approximation ratio of 3 4.
so this is regardless of the number of
advertisers in the system so idea here
is kind of like deducting proportionally
to the values um is
is this out by doing so we're sort of
able to eliminate these really low um
advertisers that place really low values
on
the user so this is able to provide much
stronger approximation ratio guarantees
than proportional allocation
um and then we also show it it achieves
value stability um for this function f
of lambda equals one minus lambda to the
negative two so this is with in
particular within our family of um
of allocation algorithms
so the takeaway here is that inverse
proportional allocation achieves value
stability and a high social welfare even
as k goes to infinity so from this
perspective it's achieved significantly
better trade-offs between value
stability and social welfare than
proportional allocation
okay so um we i've kind of described
inverse proportional allocation for uh
that is tailored to a particular value
stability constraint but we have a more
uh general formulation of inverse
proportional allocation that allows us
to interpolate across
a family of value stability constraints
and in pert and actually um
it is mere optimal for any value
stability constraint in some sense
okay so the general formulation of
inverse proportional allocation is to
deduct proportionally to a function of
values rather than just deducting
proportionally to um
the inverse of the values
so the idea here is that we set t
so that the sum from i equals 1 to k of
the max of zero and one minus t
um times g of the advertiser's value is
equal to one so we can think of this in
the picture as sort of uh replacing the
arrows where we had t divided by v with
t divided by g of v
so um
we show that if we set g of x to be 1
minus x to the power l
then this
inverse proportional allocation
algorithm is actually value stable with
respect to f of lambda equals 1 minus
lambda to the negative 2l so uh
if we kind of remember that family of
value stability constraints that we
considered at the beginning this sort of
um associates an inverse proportional
allocation algorithm with every single
um
function in that family
we also show that um inverse
proportional allocation with 1 over x to
the power l achieves um an approximation
ratio that depends on l so as l gets
larger this approximation ratio gets
larger and we see that this uh does not
depend on the number this um bound on
the approximation ratio um does not
depend on the number of advertisers so
it holds even as the number of
advertisers goes to infinity
so let's kind of to get some intuition
for this result consider the limiting
behavior so as l goes to zero um inverse
proportional allocation with g of x
equals one over x to the l um
the algorithm actually approaches
equally allocating across um all
advertisers and in this case um the
approximation ratio guarantee um goes to
zero and the value stability um
constraint becomes maximally strong as l
goes to infinity
inverse proportional allocation with one
over x to l um sort of approaches
allocating to the advertiser who values
the user most so now the value stability
constraints become weaker and weaker and
the approximation ratio approaches one
and that point um when we did inverse
proportional allocation with one over x
we got um a good value stability
constraint and also a constant fraction
of the social welfare corresponding to
three-fourths uh approximation ratio
okay so
within the family of value stability
constraints described here
we actually show the inverse
proportional allocation with the
appropriate function g um achieves the
optimal approximation ratio as k goes to
infinity so in this sense inverse
proportional allocation is optimal for
this family of value stability
constraints
we also show that it's near optimal for
a general value stability constraint so
if we take a value stability constraint
satisfying a very mild condition
there exists an inverse proportional
allocation algorithm that's values to
stable with respect to that function
and achieves a near optimal worse
approximation ratio in comparison to um
any algorithm that's value stable for
that function so in particular if we
take lambda of x to be the optimal
approximation ratio
for allocation rules that are value
stable with respect to f ipa achieves um
a worst case approximation ratio of
lambda f divided by one plus log
one over lambda
one over lambda f
so in this sense um inverse proportional
allocation is kind of achieves near
optimal trade-offs between value
stability and social welfare
so let me give a proof sketch of um
the approximation ratio theorem and then
i will give a proof sketch of the value
stability theorem and the the proofs of
these theorems and also the proofs of
the optimality results are in the paper
okay so let's first kind of uh
investigate the approximation ratio of
inverse proportional allocation
so consider um values that are uh let's
just assume without loss of generality
that the um
the values are um
in decreasing order and assume without
loss of generality that the first uh
advertiser uh values um this user one
so now um the
optimal social welfare is one so now if
we the approximation ratio is just kind
of the sum from i equals one to k of um
the value that advertiser i places on
the user times the allocation that the
algorithm
places on advertiser i
so we can kind of lower bound this by
the allocation that the algorithm places
on the first advertiser plus however
much um
the
however much allocation that um the
algorithm places on advertiser m where m
is the um the last advertiser who
achieves a non-zero allocation um times
one minus the allocation that the
algorithm placed on advertiser wants so
just to repeat this um let uh suppose
that the algorithm uh places
uh non-zero allocations on the set of
advertisers one to m and it's
not difficult to see based on the uh
properties of the algorithm that the set
of advertisers receiving non-zero
allocations is of this form
so the idea here is um
that we can truncate at uh m since
advertisers below um don't contribute to
the social welfare and then um
we uh can get this kind of lower bound
on the social welfare
so now we can kind of use the stopping
condition of the algorithm and the fact
that it uh assigns non-zero allocations
to advertisers in one to m to explicitly
write down what the allocation to
advertiser one looks like um and we can
relate that to um the value that
advertiser m so the the lowest valued or
the the advertiser was the lowest value
of the user but still receives a
non-zero allocation
and when we kind of rearrange this we
can um obtain the desired result
okay so um
to give a sense for why the uh
inverse proportional allocation
satisfies value stability
the idea is we need to analyze how um
the allocation rule changes when the
value vector changes by um some factor
uh lambda
the high level approach here
is for a given value vector find a value
vector that's multiplicatively close to
this value vector and changes the
allocation by the maximal amount
so once we've identified this value
vector we want to bound the
corresponding change the allocation so
why is this hard the challenge is that
the set of advertisers that get non-zero
allocations changes with the value
vector and it's sort of difficult to pin
down um exactly what the set of
advertisers is in a clean way
um so the idea in our analysis is to
construct modified allocations where
these sets kind of align better
so um the idea is these modified
allocations are um
are no closer than the true allocation
so bounding the uh course the difference
between these modified allocations gives
us a bound on the difference between the
true allocations
and we prove that the modified
allocations are within f of lambda of
each other so the property that these
modified allocations have is that um we
can compare like the set of advertisers
that get non-zero allocations much more
easily and
we kind of truncate the algorithm get it
to stop earlier
so that these sets are more comparable
across the two value vectors so the
details of this proof are in the paper
so that kind of gives um some intuition
for why inverse proportional allocation
gets a good approximation ratio and why
it satisfies value stability
um so to conclude i'm going to briefly
mention some of our experimental results
on the yahoo ads data set
at a high level
so first what we showed is on this data
set inverse proportional allocation is
indeed value stable
across the full spectrum of parameters l
so we looked at inverse proportional
allocation with g of x equals uh one
over x to l and um plotted some form of
these uh
value stability constraints and kind of
uh showed that as l gets larger the
auctions get less value stable but they
still satisfy some non-trivial value
stability guarantees
the second um
thing that we showed on the
yahoo ads data set is
that inverse proportional allocation
actually outperforms proportional
allocation whenever there are three or
more advertisers so in our period result
we focused on this limiting case where
the number of advertisers went to
infinity showed that proportional
allocation had a zero approximation
ratio but inverse proportional
allocation had a constant approximation
ratio um what we are able to show on
this data set is this is actually
kicking in even when there are just
three or more advertisers bidding on the
user
so um we provide the full experimental
setup and more experimental results in
the paper
so to conclude we considered fairness in
ad auctions and our goal was to design
ad auctions that don't create unfairness
in the allocation so to do so we
proposed um value stability
um which kind of was formulating
fairness as a stability requirement and
guaranteed that if the values are
multiplicatively close then the
allocations are additively close um and
this sort of allowed us to hone in on
the unfairness created
by the platform
and uh using this formulation of value
stability we designed uh the family of
inverse proportional allocation
algorithms that achieved a constant
fraction of the social welfare compared
to the unfair optimal and near optimal
trade-offs between fairness and social
welfare and um
our results also extend to uh
subset fairness which is kind of a
stronger fairness notion as well as
fairness um in more complicated systems
that have multiple categories of
advertisers so at a high level
um our work kind of disentangled the
task of ensuring fair inputs from
guaranteeing that fair inputs
lead to fair outputs and we hope that
this uh
two
step procedure can be
adapted in more generality
thank you